I remember all of you said.
Some said 4 hours, some said 5 hours,
some said 6 hours.
So, since that's not the wrong answer,
correct?
I start to memorize from last night. Ah,
you start to memorize, but was my
question from when did you start? My
question was how many hours did you
spend on memorizing? See, my question
that's specific.
If my question was when did you start,
you may have started 1 year back,
but maybe spent only 10 minutes.
My question was how many hours did you
spend in memorizing the
first 25 surahs?
Question is specific, correct?
What is the answer?
Be around 4 hours.
4 hours you spent.
Brother Zamri,
I think you above average.
If you spend four hours dedicatedly
in memorizing it is impossible unless
you're below average. And I don't
consider you below average. Maybe your
answer is wrong.
Four hours, I don't know of any average
men being that I know of
who in four hours cannot memorize 25
plus 25.
One to 25 everyone knows. Do you know
one to 25, no?
So 50 words.
50 words if you have to memorize
four hours is too much.
Think again.
No, I can
think again. I remember but I don't have
confident.
I'm asking you how many hours did you
spend in memorizing the first 25 names
and meanings of the surah. If the answer
is four,
then either your answer is wrong or
there's a problem you have normal. And I
don't consider you abnormal. Because I'm
a doctor I can make out a person who is
abnormal. But many times people give
vague answers. I'm trying to remove the
vagueness in your answers.
Very important.
Don't dodge.
Accept I'm sorry. I did not give enough
effort. I only spent half an hour.
That's matter is over. I'm spending time
why?
I'm not talking to you. Actually I'm
talking to everyone.
Whenever I talk,
please don't think now brother Zamri is
under firing squad.
I'm indirectly giving warning to
everyone. Correct?
To everyone.
Be specific.
The training you're going to start
inshallah from day after tomorrow.
Haven't started yet.
Just
introduction.
I'll give you another chance. Think
again.
I'll speak to Imran come back to you.
How many hours did you exactly spend
yesterday in trying to memorize I'll
come to you. I'll go to Imran first. Yes
Imran. How many hours did you actually
spend?
I haven't really found a way to measure
it, but I when I
first assignment was
first I saw the assignment I I thought
this this would be a lot easier than the
entire set of surahs. So, I started
working on this.
And
I I got the hang of
few surahs.
My question was not an explanation
how you spent. See, my question is
specific. How many hours did you spend
in memorizing? Did I ask for an
explanation?
A little bit every time is what
>> I don't want explanation at all. You do
your calculation what you did. You had
enough time to think.
Think yourself.
Maybe about half an hour to an hour.
>> Alhamdulillah. That's better.
Very good. You have improved.
Takbir! Allahu Akbar. Takbir! Allahu
Akbar. Takbir! Allahu Akbar. I think
he's speaking the truth.
I don't know him.
Maybe he have no problem. Half an hour
maybe you actually spent 20 minutes or 1
hour. I'm not trying to be exact
specific, but it should be from a true.
Now, if an average person spends half an
hour
in memorizing 25 names of surahs and
meanings, and if he doesn't memorize, is
it possible?
It's possible and even probable.
Yes.
Who's to blame? Zakir Naik.
Who's to blame?
Imran.
Why?
Did not put enough effort at first.
Surah Ankabut, chapter number 29, verse
number 69, you did not strive
sufficiently.
If you strive, Allah will open up the
pathway. If the pathway is open, Allah's
help will come.
Who's to blame? Imran. Will it happen
again? Inshallah, it will not happen
again.
>> Alhamdulillah. Takbir! Allahu Akbar.
Takbir! Allahu Akbar.
Inshallah, you see his result
on Tuesday.
Insha'Allah.
Insha'Allah. It will be good.
See, therefore, era banki beta cow be
zero and then become a hero. Don't
become hero first. You know, I tried a
lot and all. It's not possible.
If you strive and you don't memorize, do
you think the Quran is wrong?
Can Allah's Kalam be wrong?
Can Allah's Kalam be wrong? No.
No.
Give specific answers and you'll realize
your mistake. See, intelligent person is
someone who learns from other people's
mistakes.
An average person is someone who learns
from his own mistakes. A fool is the one
who doesn't learn from both's mistakes,
neither his nor the others.
I don't want anyone from here to be in
the fool category. Correct?
Every human being makes mistakes,
including myself.
Correct?
Insha'Allah. Insha'Allah.
You strive hard, you will get it.
And brother Kalim has selected you. He's
given you a rating.
Don't put him down, huh?
And I think he's right.
Only
he rated you smart, maybe extra smart.
Get it down to smartness
and you'll reach the target.
Insha'Allah. Insha'Allah. Insha'Allah.
Yeah, brother. Number three, Vinod.
I'll come to you later, brother. I think
I'll give him time to think and analyze.
How much time did you actually spend
on trying to memorize the first 25
surahs? Nothing more.
How much time did you spend?
Altogether, maybe around 4 hours.
Altogether from when?
From last night.
From last night, you spent 4 hours in
memorizing. What time to what time? Can
I have the break up, please? Only the
time. I don't want explanation. Give me
the time. From what time to what time
did you spend?
I went back. I took my Time to time.
Don't give explanation. Time to time.
12:00, 12:00 to 4:00, 4:00 to 8:00. Give
me time.
I'm asking you from what time do you
want the explanation?
When back home you can go back at 10:00
you can go back at 12:00 I don't know.
From what time to what time? See, I'm
asking for breakup. I didn't ask the
breakup for brother Imran. Why?
I thought he was truthful. Now, I'm
testing you.
You quoted a verse.
I'm testing you now.
From what time to what time?
9:30
>> And be before answering.
Who's staying with you in the room?
Azran Jan.
Azran Jan. Masha Allah. So, both are not
memorizing. Fine.
So, he spent 1 to 2 hours.
You spent 4 hours.
Let me know where they speaking the
surah. From what time to what time were
you memorizing trying to memorize?
Not in your sleep, huh?
If you memorize you go to sleep and then
wake up, what's the time?
What time to what time did you spend?
I don't know the exact time, but I'll
just give you a rough one. Yeah, rough
one, no problem. I started maybe around
9:30. 9:30 up to? Up to around 12:00
something.
9:30 to 12:00 is 2 and 1/2 hours
concentrating only on 25 surahs, not on
the other homework, huh? No. Only on 25
names of 25 surahs. Okay. 9:30 to 12:00.
2 and 1/2 hours.
You spent and then?
And then morning I will get wake up
early. What time?
I think so maybe around 5:00. 5:00.
Okay, 5:00 to?
Uh but I didn't after I
You got up at 5:00. 5:00 then?
What time you got up? Got up at 5:00.
I'm not asking what time you got up.
From what time to what time did you
learn? Morning maybe uh
I start around 6:30. Okay, 6:30 to?
Until I came here.
6:30 to until you came here. No, you are
supposed to leave the hotel. I know the
timing. Yeah, 7:00.
Uh so, 6:30 to 7:00. Yeah.
Half an hour. No, no. Uh maybe around
half an hour. Okay. So, according to
you, 9:30 to 12:00 is how much? 2 and
1/2 hours.
6:30 to 7:00 is half an hour, 3 hours.
If you are speaking the truth, it has
come down to 3 hours.
Not 4 hours, correct? So, answer 4 hours
was right? Or 3 hours is right?
Your answer 4 hours is right or 3 hours
is right?
I'm wrong.
First answer is wrong.
No, I'm wrong.
How the first answer is wrong?
Maybe 4 hours is wrong. 3 hours
You are wrong with both the places.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Not maybe.
No, I'm wrong.
Because I didn't count. You did not?
I didn't count.
>> No, you don't have to count.
You don't have amnesia.
You know what is amnesia? Amnesia means
what you have done 5 hours back you
forget.
There's something like recent amnesia,
there's something like past amnesia. I'm
a medical doctor, mashallah.
When you get
elderly, about 60, 70, it's common that
what you said half an hour back you
forget.
And mashallah, you don't have amnesia,
correct? Yes, your judgment may be a
little bit abstract, maybe a little bit
wrong.
You know, you think you have done a lot,
but when you analyze it's less. But from
4 hours it came down to 3 hours now,
correct?
Maybe 3 hours is also wrong, correct?
The brother time.
Actually, I
he he did more than I did.
Yes, you did 1 to 2 hours you told me,
correct? Yes. Therefore, I said 1 to 2
hours.
>> On the bus and on the way back from last
night. More than you miss more than 1 to
2 hours. Maybe 1 hour 10 minutes. Yes.
Maybe 1 hour 30 minutes.
Maybe 2 hours. Maybe 2 hours 10 minutes.
But not more than 3 hours, no?
So, because when you went to sleep, you
don't know when did he sleep, correct? I
agree with you. Mhm. That means he did
more than 1 hour for sure. I agree with
that.
How much?
Now, be prepared.
Next time when I'm asking you questions,
I like answers which are specific.
Answers which are vague are few so and
so.
And alhamdulillah Allah has given me the
gift
of taking out the truth many a time,
masha Allah.
Allah's help and Allah's mercy.
Alhamdulillah.
Brother Jan, you put 1 to 2 hours, it's
less. You have to put more.
Insha Allah. How many hours do you think
you would have put and you would have
got 25? How many?
You know, you said you put 1 to 2 hours.
Maybe if you have put a little bit more,
you would have first 125 is very easy.
How many hours do you think you would
have put and you would have
got the 25 surahs very well? Maybe
another an hour or two.
Another hour or two, very good. He spent
1 hour or two, did not get very well. If
he had spent 1 hour or two more, that
means he says approximately 2 to 4 hours
is required for him to know it very
well, and I agree with him.
I agree with him.
So, insha Allah, you'll put that.
Insha Allah. Day after tomorrow, the
homework is up to 50 surahs.
Now, you have a holiday tomorrow.
Correct?
So, going to instead of 2 hours, you
will put 4 hours.
Okay, 1 to 2 hours you have already put.
So, another 1 to 2 hours and plus
another 2 to 3 hours, average is 3 to 6
hours. It's possible
because tomorrow is a holiday.
So, insha Allah, I want you to put insha
Allah. Insha Allah. Maybe
on Tuesday, you'll know 1 to 50 very
well, insha Allah. Insha Allah. Insha
Allah. Insha Allah. Fine.
>> Allah.
Allah.